wanna up your kitchen game grab an apron
and load up these apps to bring out your
inner chef cooking is as much a science
as it is an art use kitchen dial to
measure out the exact ingredients you'll
need for instance a recipe may call for
four ounces but you only have
tablespoons and measuring cups the app
will do the conversions for you with a
weight of each food type in mind dial
can help ensure you're cooking at all at
the right temperature - by converting
Fahrenheit and Celsius you often end up
with more pasta than sauce don't you
pasta measure calculates portion sizes
if you want more linguini and who
doesn't the circle on your screen grows
hover your pasta inside the circle and
that will ensure your pasta to sauce
ratio a peb feta in addition to being a
curated recipe app handpick helps you
make the most out of what you've got in
your fridge so let's not waste their
ingredients section lets you select the
food you have on hand and suggests
recipes just check those expiration
dates like to cook but hate to shop well
hello fresh and blue apron or
subscription services that offer varying
weekly recipes and deliver pre-portioned
ingredients to your home both apps have
step-by-step instructions and even video
you can skip certain weeks or grab your
own ingredients lastly if you're feeling
completely uninspired the all recipes
dinner spinner makes life a little
easier choose breakfast lunch dinner or
dessert and then just shake your phone
and the app will give you meal options
organized around a main ingredient on
the time required to prepare the dish
you just better hope you aren't cooking
for a picky eater
you